greetings from podcast Ville the Church
of what's happening now is brought to
you by Fuji Sports listen if you're
looking for a gay shin guards Muay Thai
pads a [ __ ] mouthpiece a helmet cuz
you can't take it no more
Fuji sports.com is where you get they
deliver right the house like I said
Fugees been around to enjoy [ __ ] model
has been around so that means forever
they're guaranteed the keys I get pulled
on I got cut yesterday Lee was there
[ __ ] G's at Remender go to Fuji Sports
calm and press in church BAM and get 10%
off delivered to your house if you work
or not you need supplements so you might
as well go to Honda and get the [ __ ]
party started
start with alpha brain if that don't get
you listen to our brains a [ __ ] had a
ball in a cup of coffee in the morning
you're a [ __ ] wizard you look into
the future you understand me
you here for [ __ ] you get [ __ ]
messages from North Korea you know when
the bomb is coming that's what alpha
brain does and if it don't work it's
100% money-back guarantee you're not at
that common press in church BAM and get
10% off the Liberty hours it's 10% day
today take that [ __ ] meal Lee oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ]
are you [ __ ] kidding me or what may
23rd the Church of what's happening now
Thursday morning
ten days to d-day
oh [ __ ]
what's happening you bad [ __ ]
uncle Joey I know Wednesday afternoon I
got my main man Ed Quinn in the
[ __ ] house I got the Christ
kill of the original Lisa at and I got
kiichi the guests [ __ ] breaking hearts
[Laughter]
sexually harassing people just walking
around and [ __ ] the sexual harassment
men men just fold they fall over when
they see what's happened mr. Quinn ah
it's so good to see you see you yeah it
is better spent too long
when was one that we shoot that [ __ ]
thing kind of happened with that what
didn't happen with those people you and
I were basically gonna reinvent
television wait we were before Netflix
we were just so far ahead of the curve
we didn't know see we didn't take I
wouldn't have alpha brain back then we
couldn't see the future but that was it
when was that was that like ten years
ago
it's kind of been like 2000 was a strike
seven 2000 we deal in the strike yeah
that's right 2003 was that that'd be
like 2007-2008 and yeah we did this that
authors like I was on line pilot but the
guys behind Law & Order were creeping on
it and they were gonna try and do yeah I
was basically like law and order for
your phone or some [ __ ] like that
something creepy so yeah but it was fun
day we got to me we talked about the UFC
yep and then I see you pop it up on
[ __ ] True Blood I see you pop it up
on swinging dick on you broke girls you
know now you're on a Cuban show yeah I
know that's right I'd say crazy
yeah no it's Thing Thing two men all
right man just been grinding out but you
know it's just like nothing different
than what we were doing back then is
just trying to stay in the game and
always trying to you know happen before
all those comedies I was doing and all
kinds of weird like sci-fi and stuff
like that you just it's amazing how in
this business if you hang in there long
enough your your career just takes these
different weird now I'm doing a whole
bunch of unscripted stuff for discovery
and it's just I don't know man you just
just house it's gonna be a journey and
I've said on the show before when you
commit the universe will take care of
you yeah and it knows when you need you
know as a comic I remember not knowing
how you pay rent and it's the 22nd yeah
not having an idea eight days away from
the d-day yeah who have no [ __ ] idea
I still remember hanging outside
Kmart waiting for people to drop their
receipts and I would pick up the receipt
and go on a store and get the same item
they bought and I get the 36 bucks of
the 50 bucks like you have no [ __ ]
idea like a starving comic yeah you have
all these options and that's all yeah I
remember one day I picked up a receipt
for a 400 lawn mower and I went in there
they didn't have the loan mom like [ __ ]
so I had to drive the long run Colorado
like Kmart and I walked in I had the guy
even pick it up but then I put anything
again like five hours ago picking up on
the sled mister you'd have the receipt
and then you'd give him the receipt and
then I go into the store with the
receipt yeah just take something off the
shelf yeah this is way before cameras
and you go up to the customer service
and Ed Quinn bought me this for
Christmas I already got it
yeah you have the receipt right here oh
my get you back the cash luckily I paid
cash yeah and then I started not even
using receipt Wow just taking an item
off bringing it up gonna go my mother
got me this for Christmas can I get the
money back and they look at you a couple
times I call creepy they call the
manager over then they'd sign off and
they give you cash Wow you're like holy
crap I'm getting tax to pay me taxes
yeah [ __ ] creepy as [ __ ] you do put
the payment but to pay rent that's what
you have you know like I had to do
something some weed yeah so [ __ ]
pills whatever whatever me it could be
like when you're like a comic like that
when you do those you know cuz like you
know they say you're working on a
special you're working on being a
headline or something when you're just
getting up and doing like 10 minutes
you're not getting paid anything like
they don't even give me one even on tip
not down they don't even like give you a
only taken cover part I'm not in 1998 I
did my taxes I didn't send them in yeah
eight thousand dollars doing comedy Wow
at least I'm halfway there I got at
least I'm existing yeah what the [ __ ] I
want to do and I don't have a boss yeah
you know I'm driving to all these exotic
places like Missoula Montana
yeah I'm driving to [ __ ] uh you know
Moscow Idaho yeah like you go on places
so but that's why the attrition rates so
high I mean that's the one thing that
people don't realize is you know it's
there's so many people that are blessed
just to have been a
to exist just have been able to sustain
just have been able to keep think
because you never look at Rogan Rogan
went from what like he was out doing
multi cams the next thing you know he's
like cage fighting commentator to now
he's like one of the biggest commentator
I may be the biggest broadcaster it's
just you know how that started
no he just called Dana and volunteered
one day no [ __ ] and flew himself to
Vegas the first three times yeah Lou him
so he was just a fan he's the fan and a
participant you know that's how easy it
was yeah and how about how hard but how
it was just like you just wanted to work
just want to be a part of he was on
Newsradio
I just do remember going in New York
with him when he first started going on
the road I went on the road with him one
time I think he was making 3 grand Wow
and he paid for a first-class ticket for
both of us he lost money like right
there he lost yeah exactly
and then we did business manager was
like yeah even give a [ __ ] since day one
yeah because he had news radio and the
beginning they were paying on sitcoms
yeah one of those you could exist one of
the saddest things ever happen to me I
was starving actor I got fired from the
season finale of Frasier and it wasn't
just that I got I got paid for the
episode and I only reason I got Anthony
LaPaglia was I think he won an Emmy for
his guest star role um as Niles his
brother and he was so unbelievably funny
and we've been rehearsing I think I had
nothing I just I'd set the guy up but he
would do this one joke and that was it
it was nothing it was like it was like I
where is Anthony LaPaglia today probably
worse is living on his without a trace
money if I'm down in Australia like
making independent films and loving life
uh he was a great great guy oh no and
funny as [ __ ] no no but listen he got me
fired
he literally it was an it was the day
before we're gonna tape the season 1
hour if the wedding episode of Frasier I
just mentioned that basically he comes
storming in and I basically say
something to him and he'd done it one
way like all through all the rehearsals
and all this stuff and so I was ready it
was funny but I was ready for it was
good and he comes out and like right I
think the big network or the studio
run-through whatever
was he just turned it on its ear he did
something completely different and dude
it was like it was I it was like liver
punch it just got me it uh I didn't have
a joke to hit I didn't slow the scene
now I just broke he just he just he
clocked me he liked to knock me out it
was so funny and I and they base saw
they saw me just uh might get a little
nervous let's take like a laugh yeah I'm
a little - like you know enamored with
this dude's the you know of the comedy
and I got hooked and it was such a
bummer because I remember like as an
actor back then you got paid for that
episode but then that thing reran and it
really ran at all it's how you saw
yesterday I mean like on those little
checks those little they start us a few
thousand everyone they when they trickle
down they're just I mean I can save you
and I got that doesn't happen no more
getting hooked every day I got fired
from a Telemundo job oh they [ __ ]
hated me haha I went into the you know
I'm really good at auditioning so this
was right when you had to join sag yeah
and after no I got to be 99 98 out of
the racket and I went in for this Cuban
show by the Cuban family and I booked it
as a dorm bed mm-hm at that Club so I
was gonna return yeah I was like oh [ __ ]
I didn't know if Telemundo money was
good I didn't give a [ __ ] I want the job
yeah and I went up there and there were
Cubans and I started talking you were
born in Cuba right yeah no see you're
legit but they looked at me and how I
excuse it
and I'd rehearsed the scene I was way
too green oh no and at lunchtime when I
came back they pulled me aside they
fired me they paid me mad a payment
after yeah I got a check for like 116
because after was like 802 joy and so
yeah but here's the interesting this the
star of that show went on to be like a
big co-star in the George Lopez show on
ABC huh and when I moved to the valley I
used to walk around North Hollywood Park
and I saw him on Daniel excuse me
he was gonna tell you something yes I've
always wanted to bump into you on
apologize because it wasn't me that got
you fired
Dave there's two types of Cubans there's
like jungle Cubans like me yes in this
piece are Cubans okay you know as a kid
yeah go to Cuban girl's house and
they're moms they don't bring them on
the street yeah I speak jungle Cuban
okay even like when you are Romero is on
you rogon
I don't know that type of cute my best
friend is Cuban his name is Juan Carlos
sighs my authority yeah so yeah hey no
you know yesterday might listen my
sister [ __ ] called me yesterday
oh [ __ ] from Cuba whoa okay I was on the
phone with somebody and I saw I didn't
know the number but I knew the number
yeah and then she sent me a [ __ ]
email and when it only calls me bummer
and I I listened to the message and when
she said Jose Antonio that's my real
name
yeah it just creeps me the [ __ ] out
really my family calls me that
they don't call Coco they don't know
about Joey Diaz didn't know man flavor
nothing just just just that tone of Jose
Antonio freaks me the [ __ ] out Wow
because she says it's just how my mother
says it you know I'm Tony I'll call me
back and then she sent me a message and
I was like [ __ ] so today I've been
procrastinating the Koala yeah like all
day because I invited it [ __ ] come
here for a month
I got no passports I don't want you she
got stuck in Cuba yeah I know why don't
you [ __ ] come here for a month
meet your niece and I'll take you to New
York I'll take you to Mom's [ __ ]
cemetery you could put flowers done she
goes I'll never go to the United States
what's this conversation you know I
haven't seen her in 52 [ __ ] years
are you serious yeah she got stuck ah
you know in every fan you know Quinn and
one Irishman got stuck in your family
yeah his brother he was coming right
back yeah I'm going over to check every
family member every generation has
somebody who got stuck and happened
something didn't work out and it was my
sister so whenever I talk to her she has
that like no matter how bad I had it
growing up she had it a lot worse well
you know it's my buddies you know my
buddy's parents her grandparents had
lost lost everything in Cuba cries
American amazing story is his gran
father fought against Franco lost you
know in Spain barely got out alive got
to Cuba he's uh Franco and his dudes
walking down the street it was like nope
you know sent the family to Miami and
then was gonna you know see what
happened and sure enough you know ended
up losing everything but now his
family's going back there right now
and they're kind of doing the whole
alright this government stalling apart
give us back our give us back our
restaurant give us back our building
give us back I'm there's a lot of Cuban
Americans now I think who were going
back there and trying to figure out a
way to get their property back and that
could be I had that whole that whole
country could open up soon it could be
really interesting
I don't know yeah why don't you take a
lot of [ __ ] bad luck listen dad these
do a lot of creepy things that in the
fifties and forties yeah did you know
when I read that article about the
Superman the guy with the big dick and
godfather to that two people actually
went looking for him really that seemed
from Godfather yeah who's I talked about
on the CEO special yeah school was
grandson his grandson used to always say
my grandfather had the biggest dick and
Cuba was the guy to me Godfather - and
then he used to do the same same type of
sex show Wow it was a sexual yeah and
this article if you ever get a chance
see if you get it Superman the Cubans
because I talked about it I'm Rogan and
people liked that article was brilliant
it was to guys that went and looked at
this guy 50 years it took and they got
the origin he died in Mexico but he was
a lawnmower guy in the daytime
yeah had 90 did sex shows his dick was
like four inches in Havana and thank you
boy yeah he got paid 25 a night to do
sex shows and the people would get off
the plane and go there and they came out
the same week that Richard Pryor his
wife said that he [ __ ] Marlon Brando
this autumn I owe this reason this is
just recent yeah so this article just
came out maybe two three months ago okay
and then this article it says it goes
what Superman of a van and look at it he
was famous beyond cubist know he was
famous be on Cuban shores for his mighty
and down with a symbol of an era of sex
and sin when the revolution came he
disappeared
that ain't no the faith that's real
that's why they call him
super8 Oh God
it's a if you ever get if you have 35
minutes really this have you ever been
back no no read this [ __ ] article
they [ __ ] break it down and I'm my
friend grandmother told me yeah George
and my friend I grew up what she
listened his little girl went to Cuba no
boy no no that was just a sec say when I
was a kid my mom died to send me nine
yeah
and she'd always how are you well not
she died sixteen but my mom would always
go to me when I ran away like a pink
shirt yeah my mom would go what do you
write Hudson why do you think that and
she goes what do I think nothing rock
Hudson's gay and I'm good look really
what the [ __ ] are you drinking right
Hudson engage and say when I was a
little girl rock cut someone come to
Cuba and lock himself in a hotel room
with young boys and [ __ ] we used to go
down daily you know like when Michael
Jackson took the baby out no window
shook it like you know performer he goes
he would just stay in the hotel all
these girls are good down though they
see Rock Hudson I thought there was a
lion so if you read this article it'll
tell you that we were just a bunch of
Americans are just filthy people we were
filthy yeah we go to cue but just
[ __ ] Kennedy what the Cuban got
weight and you know who had this who had
the tape the dirtiest guy was Santo
Trafficante
because he actually flew this guy into
Miami to do a sex show they have it on
tape it's in black and white that him
[ __ ] just just like act like just a
private plane get him in Miami get him
into Miami do a sectional flying back
but his main lover was Marlon Brando
when Marlon Brando would go to Cuba and
he walked him with it says in the
article he walked him with two women and
leave with Superman him and Superman
were lovers the place was called the
Shanghai
they'd go to the Chinese [ __ ]
restaurant this is brilliant he also did
private sex shows for wealthy Americans
that's call that is just crazy man and
he was telling us he got 25 bucks a show
it's in here okay it's all in this
article so you started as a music
[ __ ] do it like yeah yeah I did know
I grew up I grew up in Berkeley and you
know I started it was
it was there's this music scene of that
the young kind of like metalheads it was
the weirdest thing but there was this
little guitar store called secondhand
guitars on the corner of Rosen Grove in
Berkeley Grove is now Martin Luther King
Boulevard and there's a candy shop and
this I mean a guitar store not much
bigger than this booth right here
and there was this dude named Joe
Satriani teaching guitar lesson till
punk little kids and I tell you man it
was there was a weirdest thing because
this is right in the heyday of like you
know Eddie Van Halen and Randy Rhoads
and like the you know the the beginning
of the whole sort of like flashy shreddy
metal stuff and you know there's Alex
Skolnick and Steve Vai and Kurt Hammett
and all these other guys I think the
guys from like Lodge rocket Exodus and
all these kind of speed metal bands and
thrash metal bands were in there and we
would all just be know we were like 13
14 learn to play guitar and we'd all
just go is our guitar teacher better
than all of our heroes cuz it seemed
like it you could walk in like you know
god I remember what the day I asked Joe
Satriani to teach me how to play
eruption I like a part of his little his
soul died he played in this band it was
a fine thing and I'm sure people who
know him know this but he played in this
like kind of poppy pop trio called the
squares and he sang and it was like it
was this thing we'd go see him like he
do these free concerts like a Zellerbach
you know a square and you know did a
berkeley community here was this 80234
wow yeah yeah and he'd do that like he's
playing and he's singing and it's not
it's not he's not like breaking into
right it's like really like almost like
I think I want I know the Romantics play
in the same thing I want to say like
he'd play to show his little band open
for like the romantics at a free you
know at a park in in Berkeley you know
like and you know so that kind of stuff
when you're walking you asleep
feelings that you keep exactly when
you're talking in your sleep good fall
good pull and so yeah and so like I
started playing and you know a lot of
guys you know there's a bunch of little
local local bands that started to do
pretty well but it also made it look
like a tough gig and I was pretty good
sports I kind of I want I was at this
all-boys high school and I was doing I
kept my grades up and I was playing in
bands how was that me and so I yeah I
you know and I just I remember having
like a conscious decision at one point
about being like because like guys that
were older than me you know they were
graduating high school they weren't
going to college and they were like
trying to make it and and there was you
know like a band laws rocket ruffians
and they were getting close and they
were putting out records and it just
seemed almost like weird you were
talking about like with the comedy thing
it's like man these guys like either is
you know the basis for a couple of them
that would come by my house and he goes
your parents home you know can guys take
a shower dude I sell a bowl of cereal I
mean like starvin like homeless like he
his family lived up the street and I
guess didn't want have to do anything
with him you know and it just it was it
was it was rough back then it was hard
back then and like Joe Satriani is
teaching me how to play guitar right
there you got man oh he's got it yeah I
got these got me walking in asking him
they all want to learn how to play you
know you know over the hills and you
know like yours it Zeppelin or lowered
or some Ozzy Osbourne you know cage up
like crazy train and sad to know you can
do it you can like turn it on you know
this like listen to it for two seconds
but yeah yeah you do it and so you know
I don't know man I just I started really
kind of focusing in on sports and you
know went to college and always kind of
had it in the back of my my back pocket
and when I first came to LA I was
studying acting and I couldn't you know
I was I was working a little bit getting
some commercials couldn't get an acting
job and started another band got another
band we started as momentum and we
started we were headline on the Sunset
Strip Edline and them whiskey and the
Roxy and the Troubadour and stuff like
that but then again you know it's like
bands are hard bands visit it's like
it's like a marriage between four dudes
and men it's just things and always
implodes and loaded with four times and
the record deal imploded and I don't
know man music is it it's the it's the
it's it's maybe one of the coolest
things to you know of the arts one of
the coolest
mediums to be a part of to be a to be a
recording artist or to be a musician
get paid but I think it might be the
hardest and now I don't know how you'd
make any money I don't know how you'd
make a living you know
that we asked her natto and Napster hit
I mean everybody just blew the music to
hold the whole music industry up and
there was you know all of a sudden your
records weren't worth anything music
wasn't working anthing was it was given
away for free on the internet and so I
don't know that some of the best
musicians I ever saw just didn't quite
make it one reason you asked everything
is what he was saying this I was
thinking if I had a chance to do it
again I would have kept calm as a hobby
really
are you serious why is that I want to do
something else
yeah like comedy is fun until you start
adding numbers up and stuff once the cop
once an art becomes a business it's a
thin line between love and hate at times
I like this but then again I just love
going somewhere and being able to say
what the [ __ ] I want to say yeah and not
it becomes it became a business you know
joy it's so counterintuitive to me
because I'll tell you something I have
always liked that second time I started
doing the music thing I was living down
a little Surf Shack and in Manhattan
Beach and I would ride my bike down and
go to the little blues bar but what the
hell was it called
and all these me uh calls closed now and
I'd go down and I would watch all these
guitars play and in my mind I've always
thought you know what you know I should
have been doing back then going to block
further to that comedy magic club and
like gone in on Monday nights on the
open mikes and maybe try to kind of like
maybe that would have gotten me into
this into the sort of maybe that the
sitcom world or under the acting work it
would have been more of kind of the work
that I'm doing now and I kind of almost
feel like now why was i spending so
Caffe bugaloo I go down a cafe bugaloo
and I watch all these you know national
tour and that would come more bluesy or
some rock kind of stuff but I mean
ripping musicians I feel like I was like
now what was I doing
oh you know what was I chasing that
dream when I could have been down
watching comics watching all these guys
come up watching all these big
entertainers watching the Leno every
Sunday I mean I could have been down and
put my time in down there and because
you're your own boss you write
your own stuff you know you like david
alan grier is a really good friend of
mine and i will be having conversations
I've seen his act fifty times or not
sixty times I love it and that changes
all the time but he and I were having a
conversation he'll be telling me some
stupid story about a girl or its car
breaking down or something and I'm
laughing he's telling to me and then all
of a sudden man like two nights later
we'll be at a club and he'll be up in
front of a thousand people and he's
telling that he was worth it that story
because I it made me laugh he's like I'm
gonna try that and sometimes they'll get
on stage and I'd watch him and it'll be
like it would work and it'll become a
part of his act and it wouldn't it
wouldn't work and it wasn't really going
on he was rear back into like you know I
didn't into his it was it was regular
act but I don't know I thought there was
a freedom to that like what I've seen
what dave has been able to do I see what
you're able to do I mean what ten days
ten days ten days he you think Vanessa I
mean think about that that's just I mean
that's just amazing and I quit
especially in this era now it's like
Netflix and HBO and Showtime and all
these guys you know all these all these
comics and all the guys that you're you
know you got this like you know this
podcast ecosystem and all of you man
it's like I've got to like literally
spend like I got my my own Twitter page
just a short sword like keep where you
guys all yourselves because I see the
lineup but this calmly still last night
no it was something from the planet it's
insane
like it was something from another plan
like both booms yeah no it was like it
started with Sebastian D'Elia Whitney
you know Rogan Bert Kreischer I think
it's a girl I mean it was just like I
looked at it and said Jesus Christ Jesus
Christ what is this see and I'm in the
circle yeah
wait that's even scarier I'm sitting
back there waiting I go up and I'm like
my heart's pounding you know ii got
earplugs on i could hear my heart
actually pushing like me go right now
and i like that is it just packed to the
gills to the gills last night Wow packed
to the gills
I saw the audience there's a little bit
when Kiki said last night believe him
that they were a little bit tight hmm
and the I opened up with a bit that
usually gets a weird responding nothing
I go I got my hand
fell in front of me interesting and I
felt gonna learn from there and I
flipped them and I did something in
Providence Rhode Island but I thought
would go over and then ate a bag of
dicks but last night at the Comedy Store
worked because I didn't say her name
how interesting I didn't say her name
see this is the part of the journey
where you learned that if I would have
said I said her name in Providence in
Providence Rhode Island there was
savages I want to thank you again for
coming out Thursday night stay with
savages and they even skin a little bit
when I said Rose McGowan okay last night
I sat on my daughter to be raised in
Hollywood end up like this crazy chick
let the cocaine in the wallet on the
plane it got a laugh okay you follow me
so they're just words yeah
the analogy of words is a weird
understanding you know sometimes you say
dick too much
mm-hm see I narrowed down to one dick
one [ __ ] you got a marriage diameter
you don't know that to you at the
40-minute mark and you go I'm talking
about dick again yeah so it's it's I
love the journey I look at the pen look
at the passion right that you got wheel
spinning right yeah and like so last
night so all these big names are there
how many of them are working new
material or like you they have a special
or they just at the Comedy Store ten
years ago you go down there a Tuesday
night and said I can go up on stage and
talk about kishi and you and [ __ ] Lee
and not give a Frenchman's [ __ ] yeah but
now they're flying in from Australia
they're coming in from Canada and
they're coming here to do business and
they're driving up from Marina del Rey
because that's part of their [ __ ]
vacation they figured the Comi store
into their trip I'm going to [ __ ]
Cali
I'm going to economy so they could buy
it they don't even care what's on the
lineup they just know that on Tuesday
night they're gonna see Bill burr they
might see Rogan they're gonna see Chris
D'Elia Sebastian they buy tickets to
Tuesday nights are always sold out da
dun dun
yeah you walk in there the electricity
did I was trying to tell you that the
best podcast
listen to my life yeah was Steven Tyler
on gyro yeah and he won I had to turn it
off as much as you do I think my music
serious yeah he said he went to Muscle
Shoals he read his timeline first of all
when he read his timeline you know how
we complain about how busy we are
he's 70 yeah you should have read his
time and they run into everything down
Monday had lunch with my kids in Venice
got in the car drove to San Diego did a
private show got in a plane overnight to
Orlando went to Disneyland to the show
with Kelly Clarkson and watching the
show yeah yeah then from there went to
New York I'm not there for three days
you know you're 70 yeah always moving
met with a Buddhist monk he hooked up
with Duncan Trussell then he went to
[ __ ] uh Marshall shows he knows just
to think listen to these words just
listen to these words he goes just to
think that I was standing well Little
Richard was standing he goes I put my
hand on the wall and he goes you could
feel it he goes then it came to me that
five feet from where I was standing
Greg Waldman told his brother let's try
that did you think of those words like I
had eternal off tears coming down my
face like that you have that deep and
music yeah he's that deep that he took
the peace and he goes I was standing
five feet from where I [ __ ] Greg
Allman told his brother yeah yeah let's
try this lick he goes thinking what I
was feeling that's the comedy store
right now yeah you go down and there's
this weird [ __ ] you know there's
weird whatever the Phenom it's an
epicenter it's an epicenter there's a
light that shines on those stages and
you could feel the pain in the walls you
know it's been done and a half or so
long that you know I mean it's like when
you go to a little music venue yeah and
the music is in there you know it's true
we did that thing and not with Dean Del
Ray
but the ac/dc did you see that hell no I
did Dean Del Ray got the bass player he
got Rudy yeah the guy from anthrax the
drummer from the Counting Crows he got a
bunch of people and they did a tribute
to ac/dc Oh No
and while we were down there the guy
gave us a tour yeah of who was in there
yeah and he goes right here you know
just think about it right here Albert's
today like it was where somebody did
somebody bought that place in the 50s Oh
Dean Martin because I was close to his
office
oh yes Oh Dean Martin would go over and
do comedy at night with yep and Jerry
Lewis I'm sitting there going are you
[ __ ] kidding me
yeah that no matter what you say in
there that spirit that energy is still
stuck against those [ __ ] wall
you know what's so interesting you say
it cuz I just just got back last week he
was doing a movie in Cleveland and I was
like me one thing I'm two things I got
to see I got to see a Cavs game got to
see the cabs close out the Toronto
Raptors whatever was which was electric
by the way I mean no it was it was just
I'm not even an NBA fan just started
sitting there like looking around going
yes it's big minute what the rock'n'roll
Hall of Fame and who was it was really
kind of humbling and sobering in a
really it's almost like when you it's
like you'd go see like a you go to a
museum and you see like an old suit of
armor they've been in battle and it's
like in some way it looks a lot smaller
and a lot bigger than you thought it was
going to you know it's like you kind of
see it you're like oh look at that and
then all of a sudden it's just like it
has this aura about it I'm just going
through and seeing all Bowie's stuff and
princes stuff and and and every time you
turn around there is like you know it's
one artist but that artist represents so
many stories and so many songs and so
many emotions they put out it's heavy
it's heavy and so it's yeah it was it
was almost over one was almost too much
because it was just like it was you you
know every every step it was it was a
new artist it was a new whole catalog of
music a whole
how many eras some of these you know
musician seeing Jimi Hendrix's guitar
just s even Stevie Ray Vaughan's guitar
and just sitting there you know besting
especially the ones that were alive when
I was you know a kid and then never gone
now and it's just I know he's even more
heavy how long you study with Joe
Satriani for I like 3-4 years maybe he's
so friendly with you not at all no idea
I would never I mean I'm sure if I
walked up to him I met him and told him
he'd probably laugh it was probably
great no it was like this weird thing
where man one day he was just gone I
think it was like he got on tour
with Frank Zappa maybe or some someone
finally went what I'm taking this guy on
toward me and then the minute like he
kind of got out of you know Berkeley
maybe or just he got in front of an
audience or Easter came along and you
know one minute he was there next minute
he was gone and then you know a few
years later surfing with the alien came
off and we were just I mean we're just
all so proud everybody told me that
right and Burbank was Randy Rhoads his
mom and him taught music I probably yeah
I mean I'm just a little storm Burbank
yeah I mean oh I don't know I say it's
wrong I don't want to feel it like yeah
that you can fact check absolutely
everything I say and I will not be
offended if you know I'm yeah hurt
somebody came in I don't know I think it
was Rudy who gathered that yeah he used
to teach guitar lessons right on the
claw when someone's that good when
someone's Brandi roads good it's it's
usually they loved it so much that they
do I know so many actors that teach
acting cuz it's just like it's something
they're really good at and they're
passionate about and you also learned so
you know it's like anything man like
you're really good at something so now
you're teaching someone from you know
the basics and as you're teaching them
the basics you're like sure I kind of
forgot some of the basics I should be
actually paying attention to this this
is like the simple ABCs of anything of
any art of any you know craft of
anything and so um yeah I wouldn't
surprise me that someone like Randy did
because Randy was he was next-level good
you know there's there's the the savants
like you know like a Jimi Hendrix or
something and then there's you know
someone like Randy Rhoads who is just
seems to be changed the game like he
changes the game like there was bad Alan
Van Halen was [ __ ] rocket yeah I mean
more of a savant chili I don't know if
he could read music yet they work on
thing they destroyed all that
yeah but I'm about not some person yeah
after the weed store yeah
about maybe 18 months ago one damn
listen to Monday every Monday I listen
to Sirius dye any Rock Eddie yeah yeah
at one show I love that show
he back he's doing a top 20 hit that I
just got a tweet like his podcast here
we are just can't remember his name
he's doing a podcast like today of like
his top 20 I love love that
the car yeah I listen to Eddie when I go
to New York
Eddie truck a truck Eddie truck and it's
weak because Dean Delray is good friends
with mandingos Antonio I'll get you on
the show yeah I'm a big fan is on us I'm
a fan that he could do a podcast by
himself at three [ __ ] hours wait he
knows everything
searching for no names either things
call yeah yeah as a Gaston yeah no I do
love there's always things like like he
loves old UFO which is something that
and he loves Wyant each other yet Dave
medication shows that I forgot to tell
you well then after all right so when I
got on the plane I'm superstitious yeah
it's fell on what it's it's sound the
winter yeah whatever that song by Bush
maybe twice yeah they're not put a fell
on black days maybe like 13 times yeah
what do you think the next song is is a
UFO UFO strangers in the diet [ __ ]
rock Bob rock pile guess they have
horror on that but also the beginning of
doctor doctor it's one of the most
beautiful things live I've ever heard
him well I put it on holy yeah
doctor doctor lives just the first four
core I don't like what it becomes yeah
is it a video order stay on yeah I'm
just whatever you want whatever is
easiest for you just to listen to dr.
daughter to live UFO with shaker oh oh
his first solo album yeah second one
yeah and I was a kid when the same SK my
oh my god and he tore last year did he
really yeah with all the three singers
what's this everything is yeah uh yeah
rock bottom's on my life work out
there's no shirt didn't give a [ __ ] do
you like what's 17
[Music]
un-fuckin'-believable
[Music]
shoes you know he auditions for Ozzy
Osbourne no does he call them a [ __ ]
Nazi a fictitious ha ha see [ __ ] turn
talk call him a Nazi he put his guitar
this thing and ran the [ __ ] out of the
studio but no I listening to the beat I
listen to rock bottom maybe five or six
times especially the guitar solos I like
both the other live good there's
something like the studio it's so raw so
we and how we forgotten how to make live
music yeah yeah we've had this
conversation I'll fin does that because
it's it's there's so much soul behind
that and so much power but it's I hear
it immediately and like those guitars
aren't that saturated there's not a lot
of distortion it's not like all these
racks and all this stuff that they're
running through it's all not this
incredibly big even live like produced
and processed sound it's just so dry and
clean and yet it's just
drum and bass and guitar and it's his it
doesn't need that much and we forgot we
forget when you read Keith Richards book
he has a whole chapter on that we
thought about it so much technology to
Norway like we forgot how to make a live
perfect example of guitar tone that's
like so classic and so all my Mateus I'm
Keith Rich's on some girls yeah the
whole [ __ ] out yeah no no Rich's on
black and blue yeah a whole [ __ ] out
Keith Richards all somebody just gave me
exile and I left it at the house they
just gave me Exile on Main Street
Tuesday Thursday no no ants
oh my god some guy gave me Exile on Main
Street I want to thank the lady who
[ __ ] made oh my god in New Jersey
they just handed me a bag with it was
like those circles will you call those
cakes that people make him a circle bun
cake like a bundt cake yeah moist is
[ __ ] it was like uh I don't know what it
was it was delicious she made these
white chocolate coconut oatmeal cookies
me and Matty one apiece I remember they
were [ __ ] delicious then she made to
marijuana cookies no and I think I buy
that cuz I can't have it was delicious
and I don't cook your note and I don't
know what I did with you know and I'm
sorry I don't
acknowledging you but I'm if you're
listening thank you for bringing me the
[ __ ] pound cake whatever it was was
out of this world they bring me some
great [ __ ] these people in my showers
now you still go to an acting class you
know I don't as much but I would that's
the whole thing I don't really go I just
you know life and just trying to keep my
head above water and stuff but I gotta
say sometimes I will go I'll go back to
class just because I like to watch it I
like to watch the process I'd like to
watch other actors you know the class I
always went to you know you'd have all
the class be working on one scene so you
and I be doing the same character all
three of us you know we would normally
never audition maybe for the same thing
but now we're all working on and maybe
it's something maybe it's your audition
that you got going on but the whole
class is putting it up and the girls
were all different they're putting it up
and you just watch people make different
choices and that to me I don't know it's
like you were saying about you know too
many dicks you're always learning you
know you're always learning what works
what doesn't work going back to the
basics and so I'm just I kind of exiled
myself from you know the one thing that
keeps me sane in this town is being kind
of out of the town and so I am down in
the South Bay down at the beach and that
just you know allows me to recharge my
batteries and come up but it's also it's
a long way to come up and sit in the
acting class for you know four or five
hours everything see what did you go to
originally when you've done here
ariza the first acting teacher I had was
a woman named Janet all honty and she
was fantastic but man I don't think I
learned anything cuz it was like all
this like repeating my nurse I was all
this theory acting and then I get an
audition I'd be like I don't know what
I'm supposed it was crazy like we'd be
doing these long scene all this theater
stuff you know I'm like then you get an
audition from Melrose Place there was a
couple cats or like famous cats camera
their name I went to them and then a
woman named Leslie Kahn that I that's
how I got that job with you yes yeah
exactly yes we can't contact them
because I did a couple privates with it
yeah yeah and you know whatever I did
the issue was worked on Luis Guzman when
I booked this pilot yeah yeah I was
pretty impressed in that sometimes I
think about going to acting classy but
what's he like her going on yeah we have
nothing going on and like her classes
are like in
you know you're sitting in like a living
room and like I said like I want to
watch eight actors who I never will
never read for the same thing
I want to see them do I either want to
try and do their material and I wanted
to see them do my material because I'll
learn something from that you know it's
it's watching watching young and you
know like I'll go into some of her
younger classes you know like as a TA a
terrible teacher
I'm gonna go more but like a football
coach so like wow you're doing a rock
you look like this and that's not the
way you you know
coach acting but so I rather just sit
and watch and then like watch her
develop students and watch students sort
of like come into their own and because
that's the thing is you're just you're
always learning in this bit what all the
businesses you know music as well you
know it it depends I've been doing a
bunch of like kind of unscripted stuff
I'm learning about that kind of stuff
like you know doing more almost like a
hosting of shows and so yeah there's
some there's something really to me at
least there's something really rewarding
and like Advent ages about popping into
a class you know just going once a week
you know and then work on some stuff and
just cuz you can get stuck get in a rut
think your nail and stuff think you're
doing great and all sudden you go work
with some people and you know everybody
else is like as cool as you think you
are you know you know you know kneecap
you a little bit you know like you know
get to get get you to reset and well you
need that like last yeah I drove all
over Burt and I was when I dropped bird
off it's funny cuz it was 11:30 maybe
11:45 and I was energy from the store
woke me up it was like I went to
Starbucks and got a [ __ ] coffee yeah
and I looked at Burt and I gave him the
old Joe Rogan lion-o you really want to
go home yes he goes where we gonna go I
go I know a place
yeah woman I'll show you a [ __ ] for a
dollar and he just looked at me there's
a dollar and then I went it's a joke get
out of the [ __ ] car and then I call
Jonah yeah joe
just wait where are you and I go I know
a place where you could see him
his [ __ ] for a dollar I started
laughing on the phone he goes one how
old is that [ __ ] joke I got 98 yeah
oh my god it was that that was one of
your jokes on your first CD uh I was
proceeding I was trying those things got
me the trouble for going to a strip club
or something yeah and the guy said to
what are you doing here because I know
that was a joke mojo rug so when I
dropped bird off I just drove round and
I was on a call leave we had just left
the movies yeah and I was thinking about
calling Lee and having to meet me a yum
yum donuts talk about comedy yeah but I
go we're gonna eat yeah that's the last
thing I need is sitting there because
we'll do it yeah yum yum donuts is
dangerous in North Hollywood I've
thought about going and getting a cup of
coffee you got a show in ten days no
going in there I can going cuz you open
24 hours yeah she's going here with your
computer got a cup of black coffee you
go right till 2:00 and see people who
are coming in yeah watch that's the
beauty about life you go to a coffee
shop I'm right and I'm watching I'm
hearing conversations I'm listening to
share sure just to just get something
different but I don't trust young young
no Mitch I don't want to be in then get
wrong get a man like it's right off the
[ __ ] 101 I was gonna Rob enjoy 35
bucks I get shot me I wanna be in there
[ __ ] through in the morning no I
don't want to end up beating [ __ ] 22
doughnut yeah if you sit with doughnuts
you gonna be a Weight Watchers you
didn't say top the [ __ ] sit there and
smell those fresh doughnuts and Mexicans
make an apple glazed donut over there
come rock with little chunks of apple in
the middle only Mexicans could do that
I tell we like really really really
really white people go there and ask
questions yeah lady don't know what the
[ __ ] is going on like she has no idea
the language yeah they're like what
flavor chocolate like chocolate
chocolate and she don't know and how
many calories in that chocolate
chocolate this is the gluten-free
chocolate chocolate like they hire like
the women that cannot speak [ __ ]
English yeah it's a [ __ ] great place
it's small but my head was gonna blow up
last night because I just did six shows
I ain't [ __ ] one of those shows
Friday night late in Jersey I go to the
comedy store my first five minutes eats
a bag of dicks now it's very uh but yeah
grounding grounding yeah when you kill
in Providence in New Jersey with a bit
and then you call in LA and you don't
kill with that bit and what you want you
won't you want to be the kind of the
sociopath who doesn't think about Jersey
and doesn't think about the first five
minutes might be the person only rides
that high life that person is just like
oh I'm killing it and though that but
like I think you know like real artists
or people have been in the business a
long time it's almost a
self-preservation thing you're like yeah
don't don't hurt yourself patting
yourself on the back for the good ones
you know the jobs you've got or the
auditions you kill the Dingley away it's
the ones where you just go in
faceplant and those are the ones you
just go man what what was I thinking
what happened well I go I forced myself
about six seven months ago to go to an
open mic once or twice a week will you
pay five bucks there and you do five
minutes and that's it with kids and that
has helped me I seem that we're just
talking about dad has helped me a lot
because and are you watching the kids
though I'm watching the kids studying
him studying studying learning from them
like the [ __ ] I used to do didn't do why
his set went bad yeah he went bad yeah
you know yeah I watch the kid that set a
brilliant line but he stepped on it he
didn't let it settle in the room yeah
you fart it comes out of your ass and it
spreads yeah a joke does the same thing
yeah you learn that through time it's
like a fine wine that man joke will
catch but if you step on it it's not
gonna catch I learned that acting 101
well yeah why don't you know aspect
with that in multicam yes that that
happened to me a couple of times where
I'd like said something funny it didn't
quite hit and and all of a sudden it was
just I realize it you know you can you
can actually even get the audience to
laugh they won't laugh right away but
they'll let that joke sink for a minute
and all of a sudden boom and here it'll
calm and you can't let them sink and do
it Rodney did give them permission to
laugh Rodney touched his tie which gave
you permission to laugh now it's a
psychological [ __ ] game you know when
to laugh yeah okay yeah you're gonna
laugh every time I do this with my neck
you're gonna laugh I'm training you to
[ __ ] laugh yeah that's the
psychological warfare it becomes a
warfare in your mind yeah you figure out
and when I go to those open mics I leave
they're more wired than when I go to the
Tommy store why is that I've learned
more from watching those kids yeah I
think that we're actors comics anybody
in a high-profile position loses it like
Kanye West and you're not grounded and
you never remember where you're coming
from
yeah you had to I don't go to that open
mic and give advice to I don't tell kids
what to do now shut my mouth and watch
and if I become friendly with a guy and
I see he's friendly and understanding I
will offer my advice to them but I'm not
there to coach nobody know I go there to
watch them and I know they learn as much
from them as they do from watching me
yeah and it also humbles me it makes me
remember that time in my career yeah
when you're frustrated yeah things
aren't happening you working at Burger
King
you're living in a closet but you have
put any hours yet then you haven't put
in the hours boots you [ __ ] could
taste it yeah want it yeah when I go to
the fourth wall I know one thing for
sure those kids want what I have
yeah and I want what they have that
peace of mind yeah I want that Mick
Jagger wrote you know when Jesus is down
in pain yeah that's the biggest problem
we have as actors and comics
what fills our avoid when we have those
doubts and those pans of like what music
were you had yeah you know you put it
into perspective yeah I did I did you
really did I was almost scared of it I
was almost scared of it i
compartmentalize it in a weird way i
mean like if if quitting something is it
isn't maybe if that's admirable but i
always and like when i'm when the band
last band that I broke up I had some
really big big a-list famous musicians
and bands approached me to become their
guitarist like I'm going on stage I'm
not I'm not I'm not some virtuoso I'm
not the best guy in the world but the
the people that the people that book the
shows at the whiskey and the Roxy or
like you you're good and that you could
be you could be a big touring and I was
like I just I don't I want to be like
touring with some you know you know I'm
some big huge recording artist but do I
want to be that am I even good enough no
I'm the road Zakk Wylde and the bus know
is for 60 days [ __ ] playing riffs on
a guitar so now listen I did it I mean I
wish you know there's times and I you
wish you a single you wouldn't have
killed you so you could really do that
one more yeah we will get in the car
tour yeah the [ __ ] car you're driving
but when it's snowing I don't do 60 your
[ __ ] we gotta be there by later you know
yeah and a hotel that smells like Hindu
yeah you know the people who owner the
Hindus it smells like curry yeah you're
up in your [ __ ] room you hear people
[ __ ] next door no hot water you know
your bed smells like Cologne
you check the long enough you have no
idea Lee when you're in the bed and you
could smell the Cologne and the hooker
that [ __ ] there now before you got into
the room and you gotta go do comedy at a
bar and there's a drinking contest
before you go up yeah like before you go
up on stage there's five guys on stage
doing drinking concerts I want the
Chapel Hill yeah you know I love college
basketball yeah Cuban American College
[ __ ] basketball college football it's
[ __ ] great I love all that [ __ ]
and I what the University of North
Carolina may be like
nine and I walked in there with like I'm
a regular at the commies table ripped
this [ __ ] room apart yeah and they
were having a drinking contest and the
guy comes up to me that I don't like a
guy pukes and they're like you know
you're following drinking coffee five
minutes now and you're on and I went up
there and I was so rattled by the
drinking contest I just ate a bag of
dicks
like I just that's experience that's the
journey man and but the thing that you
do choose like you know like you focus
you know mainly on comedy and focus
mainly on acting and then I think there
is really something too you know
everybody's always about think positive
and magic your Vision Quest board
wherever the hell it is and you know and
only be positive positive sometimes I
think it's good it's sort of as an
artist you want to be able to sort of
you know straddle the side of the light
and darkness and you know when your
things are going good it's really easy
to just be sort of confident move
forward everyone small something goes
bad it's good to kind of check yourself
it's good to kind of examine that and
like that's the thing about comedians I
think is that you know like you were
saying there was that line up last night
and I bet you were all there though I
like did different points like someone
just finished their special someone's
you know working on new material they're
gonna do you've got ten days you know
it's d-day for you it's like you know
someone else got some huge corporate gig
and they're trying to like do something
clean and you guys are all up there
working on material for a different
reason but all working you know and all
learning and all like and focused and
you know you know for most of my life I
just went to comedy clubs and just died
didn't understand that what was going on
I'd see the matrix of it I just was like
guys guys are gonna be a challenge out
school I was until I met David and saw
what went into it saw how I keep you on
the show
did show get canceled he had a mortgage
he had some alimony he please out on
roads on the road you know there's a way
in brothers that you know so him start
doing that and and how he did that and
how he nurtured it and how he respected
it and and then like you know it kind of
threw the podcast world that you just
started to learn so you know intimately
about all of these comics not you know
not Bob Hope and not Eddie Murphy and
not that the biggest top of the top but
it's like all these guys who are like
the you know like the grinders and the
the the main yeah the main lifeblood of
the comedy scene right now and you can
learn so much about them listen to
comedy you know listening to the podcast
and what they do when what the grind is
out fascinates me and it's kind of I
think it's something that you can also
sort of take to your everyday life no
matter what you do you know that kind of
thing I've always be working this is
general when I talk when I talk about
calmly again a couple of months yeah a
hundred percent I could be talking about
drywall and I can talking about
electrical work roofing I could be
talking about or I can't compare it to
like engineering or something like that
because I don't really know that's four
years of college yeah but he went but
you went to college 30 years ago that
[ __ ] that's that's all gone like it's
all it's everything changing as well
everything's evolving or like killer
here in tech you fight you know
everything five minutes ago dude you
told ill news old business and so you've
always got to be opening yourself up to
that and you know and that's I don't
know it's like it's just like I can't
wait for 10/10 it's crazy that you got
fired like we all get fired like I
almost got fired from a commercial cuz
I'm going off I'm a director but I had
every right there you wanna says you
know I get there and I see the Hat with
the feather yeah and the tattoo with the
t-shirt you know if you get to a set and
you know who the director is by the
Wardrobe you that problem yeah you know
and it started getting like that yeah
yeah I did one show the chick was a
chubby lesbian with a French poodle you
know we're directing him
yeah the French pool at the [ __ ]
house with the assistant yeah and she's
a half a lesbian and nobody knows what
the [ __ ] is going on it's too much drama
funcle' Joey yeah shoot a [ __ ] movie
with Sam Raimi with the same suit on
every day yeah eccentric you know yeah
yeah I don't need that's why I don't
sometimes sometimes I have a great time
acting and sometimes it's a weird time
sometimes it's like what the [ __ ] am I
doing here sometimes I like sick times a
lot because you're in and out yeah and
it's and and and show night show night
man that's show business to me that's
what that's one thing I love about
that's what a lot of actors don't like
about it is it's like all of a sudden I
mean I love it cuz you rehearse all week
and everybody tinkers with I love
shooting the live show the audience
I haven't done it in 15 years Tom really
Wow she's like even when I shots a
period doughnuts they should be on tape
okay shot Friday but they go would just
wish you John Day dawn Thursday and the
last two you have been just closed sets
I did I'm dying up here close ho sad but
for years I would pilots the Fox yeah
and Friday was a live performance and
I'd [ __ ] kill
I'd kill of course you would that
improvised and it really pissed the
[ __ ] actors off they would crack I
got this Lee five Luis Guzman late them
the show got picked up no yeah no like
you're in no danger
oh you were a problem on this set that
wasn't a problem yeah he said that he
wanted me to say a word that wouldn't be
said in New York City yeah that one
Puerto Rican would not say the other
tears a Mexican words and I corrected
the [ __ ] direct angle isn't enough
for nothing poor Ricans are usually
words yeah it was like he's gonna use
what the [ __ ] line says yeah the way
he responded to me like that really like
somebody would be open yeah but the way
he responded to me I was like [ __ ] you
[ __ ] man I did the thing anyway in
years later I seen him at the store and
he came over and apologized oh that's
not yeah like I saw him at the joining
man the fog of war people get like you
know I've been on so many sets and you
know it's crazy and people are having
real nervous breakdowns people aren't
tons of pressure or people weighing over
their head and you know and then like
you know you get through it and you make
it and it's fine and then no years later
like you say you'll be like it you know
Trader Joe's or something or to come in
and you'll see somebody look like I'm so
sorry you know I was just a bag a letter
I got letters from like people who were
just like oh it was a mess and I was
going through a bunch of stuff and you
know you were totally right and I didn't
mean it like over staff or be like this
and I know I'm sick I know we got it we
made it I don't know I did the long
leash are the director hated really like
from the second week we hold no way
because I went to have them no political
movies you directly she's the boss yeah
so you're telling me to do something the
boss is telling me do something with the
boss tone I'm sorry so I would do it the
boss time and he will get
so we clashed and then at the and I
loved him telling his wife and that the
premiere yeah okay told me goes you are
not my first choice at the premiere
hello and I was like okay you know you
felt you had to say that you need a
three beers so [ __ ] ten years later I
got an audition and I am DB it yeah I'm
like oh god dad she's the [ __ ]
director Wow i'ma call cancel yeah no
you know what no no you're not
it's right here more the brothers just
go and do your best if he season he
don't want you and when I walked in i
had knew the casting director the Puerto
Rican guy yeah I forget what his name is
I said something to him and he'll do me
a favor if you talk to Peter tell him
I'm sorry I got clean off drugs I don't
do drugs no more yeah look Li talking
about he's the one that requested you
sake so I was like oh [ __ ] now
things change and sometimes you know
sometimes it's just the business to like
look there's been twice up in fire
there's another show that was kind of a
train wreck called coupling and I walked
in and walked out and before I got to
the car my phone was ringing out booked
a job I'd you know some half hour you
know the dude I can't remember the role
was and I got to the table read though
and they sat down they saw it and
they're like he's just - I was - I
wasn't cheesy they're like you know
those things that I couldn't correct I
was she wasn't cheesy enough they're
thinking more like a cheesy blonde guy I
was actually I had chemistry with the
girl I wasn't supposed to have chemistry
with her and it was all do I was wrong
but I need to find a dude so they kept
me for the whole like but you know I so
you started to start on like gonna be a
Monday or Friday I get the job Monday
I'm there the table read Monday they
want it they don't get rid of me but
they don't think they need someone to
come in so Tuesday Wednesday
it's like Thursday we're calling through
the whole thing and like I could feel
the director was kind of like trying to
get me to make different choices which I
totally was and and all of a sudden man
it was like this like someone comes up
and goes hey ed phones for you
and I'm like what everybody's gone there
was I think it was there was the set
phone in the Allah God in the goddamn
stage and I mean cockroaches like
there's nobody left on the entire stair
first 100 people don't know is there
there's this one phone walk back a
little
I'm like Hello is my manager she's like
hi ad I'm like I like it fired she's
like yeah my god dammit
hang up the phone walk out and one actor
stand out there it's a guy named Colin
Ferguson and he walks me to my dressing
room and he goes do this shows best by
the way this episode never even aired
that's how the show was like really
coming apart it seems walk me there walk
me back nicest guy ever director called
me this afternoon he just was like buddy
I'm you know I could tell you were
trying to like get me to do different
stuff and something goes and you were
doing it it's just like you're just
you're too big you're too handsome and
you're just like we're wrong for the
role you blew him away in the room like
all day all excited for you just don't
work for the role which was all fine
show never even aired
so I wouldn't have gotten any paid and
then Colin Ferguson turns out to be the
lead of Eureka like a year later he and
I are on that series and you prefer four
years now we're best friends instead
we're always gonna look back and laugh
on it but was that kind of thing so it
was like the whole thing it didn't
really matter on the end in fact it's
funny I'll never forget that moment of
like you have a PA like say it was a
phone call for Michael for me times one
word order but it go edition of Fox one
day through that show on CBS
yes I'm Bob your mother how I Met Your
Mother
Tommy yeah there we go I had a little
hole like right here and heads like like
nothing you couldn't see nothing it was
a hole in the seam of the gene mm-hmm
like a little tiny hole yeah something
that happened it was too late I was in
the car already at peak oh yeah so the
casting people were not gonna see the
hole there was no way they were gonna
see the hole yeah at the time I didn't
wear underwear degrees Oh walk into how
i met your mom's er Bernard Secession
all right
it's a producer [ __ ] truth do
Secession they're looking for somebody
but they don't know who they're looking
for
yeah my manager at the time said just go
in and rock their world it's a comedy
yeah just gonna rock their world yeah so
it was a scene where I was sitting down
and I have to get up and and something
happened
there's three women in the room and the
gay guy know and I'm sitting down and I
get up and the pant got caught this
could only happen to me the man got
caught in something this guy got up it
just went on and it ripped you heard it
go on like the jeans just rip on the
corner whatever the [ __ ] I had on ripped
and I stood up and my ball was hanging
and I looked at all Michael you like the
Cuban I grow and they [ __ ] fella they
fell out and then I just ran with it
I just ran with it after that you'd like
the Cuban n girl I'm sorry the Harvey
Weinstein this is 12 years ago I'm going
off about my nut underwear my wife
didn't do the lawn just went off yeah
they were dying yeah I remember them
going thank you for coming in and I was
halfway to my car my agent calls me
GoPro go back you didn't read for them
oh we were in there talking about the
RIP in the pan there so long as they go
go back I went back I read don't like
thank you for coming back we oh my god
we you crank this up so game was smitten
yeah gave me the job right now but time
I put the key in yeah yeah Paul came
here go to your fitting go to your
fitting with bah-bah-bah and the next
day I went in there the director hated
me he looked at me I can just see his
face skull not disc oh and if you watch
the episode play I'm basically an extra
they gave me like 2,300 yeah till he an
extra they cut my line out and then made
me sit there and I mean I was in and out
of there that's how much they hated me
yeah but that's but they began and then
you'll probably see the director again
you'll request you go yeah that guy's
perfect that's guys great it's like
everybody's so kind of
compartmentalizing that's one thing
that's one thing to learn and one thing
you know you're talking to like young
actors you're talking to you know be
pissed it's it's so you can't you should
personalize some stuff and you should
like you have a bad audition or you you
know you know eat a bag of dicks on your
first five minutes whatever you said
it's you should think about that and
that's because that's part of your craft
and party your responsibility as an
artist and how you grow you also got to
realize you know what something like you
know a director doesn't like you or just
didn't go well and I cut all your lines
I'm at
do I have like 400 hours of stuff that
I've shot that's been cut out of movies
and TV shows and stuff or and stuff that
you didn't get wasn't he wasn't your
fault it was like yeah dude you're just
you weren't right for the role you
weren't it didn't work it like this is
what we got we were trying to like put
you in and it was just like what's this
[ __ ] water ball don't know you got
here and so it's just it just is that
kind of thing and so you know like I
love that story that that one director
like he requested you to come back you
thought he hated you from before yeah
but yeah but also he's like I hate you
for that job ten years later yes
straight up hate you for that job we
talked about it yeah oh god yeah I put
him on the podcast oh nice a nice we
talked about you know what happened he
goes there was so much going on yeah he
goes I've never really worked for Adam
since then no yeah this is almost twice
going on this is too much yeah that's
what I say like before I didn't mean it
as a comic I really loved the art I
could teach it I loved it I'm doing 27
years yeah all the way in the belly
I am pre you know I didn't you said it I
didn't I didn't put it together for the
first two years no my first three years
as a comedian I did not put it together
so I saw John Leguizamo doing open mic
interesting at all
oh so you gotta work yeah you know
Leguizamo was at a place with a people
one guy getting a [ __ ] under the
table it's 1:30 in the morning then on
the Hell's Kitchen yeah I'm legless I'm
all thought he was in Madison Square
Garden
it was the most brilliant thing I've
ever seen like ah so he put it together
for being on a plane went to Colorado
and just went yeah man read books on
that did the work books then just you
know and I had a twist to it because I
was going through a divorce
hmm I don't have to drop my daughter off
on Wednesdays and Sundays it was so
painful no so I would have a joint in
the ashtray and as soon as I would drop
her off I'd get back in the car and I'd
forced myself even though I was crying
and I smoked that joint I'd forced
myself to go do comedy you have no idea
what it's like to walk into a place wipe
your tears as you're walking into the
place yeah and I have to be funny 15
minutes late I did it on purpose like I
forced myself to
Wednesdays and Sundays I used to drive
to our valid at the time it was a
whirlwind dancing class from 7 to 8 and
the comedy star than 8 before people
yeah you know and Here I am broken
inside angry pissed yeah bro hungry you
know the bar gave you a drink ticket in
you cash in there like a sandwich you
listen I don't want a drink can I get an
order of fries yeah like that type of
[ __ ] we need just he fries You Know Who
am I but trust me those fries are good
like a mother thing yeah you put salt on
each one like each one you pick it up in
your like you put you put man on it
yeah you must like this like this and
the mustard us to get a little more you
load a bucket a couple more carbs in
there and you sit there like you know
even as an actor a musician you always
what do you do when you get that down
like when I told Lee that one day you're
gonna be sitting in the copy room if
somebody's gonna fall off the stage and
you every it's like every six months
comes the moment of truth where you have
to actually stop and look at yourself in
the mirror and go am i getting anywhere
with this and be as brutally honest with
yourself
like there's no time frame you come out
to this yeah now you're gonna take the
ride you know I've seen many people come
and go and they quit and I'm not mad at
them for quitting know this is a hard
Leslie counties to give parties to
people who quit if you quit acting in
the urine class she'd you have a pizza
party
they literally like congratulations you
got the [ __ ] out like almost like
getting like like graduated from the
program something like it was like
literally like a job what was the last
time you saw Leslie I talk to her all
times what am i descendant hello I won't
say no I will for sure yeah yeah I used
to have a crush on her go yeah I misuse
that she's the queen and she's just the
sweetest thing on the planet and she's
probably does she still live at the
place all week and then drives home to a
husband on the weekend [ __ ] crazy
crazy no you know what she's Daisy she
does by the way like an interesting side
story I actually I think to her bedroom
at the place is all furnished by stuff
that I've brought back for I called her
from Indonesia I was in Tunisia surfing
got hurt
the hyper-extended my knee tore half my
foot off was in too much pain to fly
home but so I was just there in Bali
with I got
with a cane and limping around so I just
bought a house and the house was empty
and I couldn't afford to put anything in
it but not always
unbelievable furniture it was so cheap
and like to buy you buy all this
furniture and you dip it and it would
still be like a quarter of the price of
what it would cost if you went down like
on Melrose and bottle this beautiful
Balinese crap I called her I go I got
I'm trying to fill out a shipping
container
she's like fill it up so her whole bed
it's like canopy beds you open it I was
at that crazy like acting school and you
open up like this Balinese palace in
this one room does she still have it
like that yeah and I like her and her
husband like they lived way out they
move closer to town now they live liked
it not not as far away so she look like
she can go home at night now it's still
the way it was that day acting all dudes
like they same place same place 17
freakin classroom I think it's bigger
now man 17 classrooms going full-speed
it's just mayhem yeah I like so many
young actors so so many actors have been
able to like you'd like you're talking
again we're talking about like how do
you make the ends meet or look like
right now it's May and nobody got a
pilot everybody freaking out I can pay a
mortgage I can do this
everybody teaching classes everybody
working around you know coaching
everybody there's there's it's it's such
a good ecosystem for actors learning
like you know dude I didn't even get an
audition I a new manager who's your
manager do you know anybody your agent
and so it's just like you know the best
thing I think that she created was a
community for people to really be able
to just figure out what's going on
figure out the business get a breath you
know like it's all comes at you so fast
and I mean it's Hollywood that's crazy
you're not gonna learn anything going
and hanging out the ivy or getting drunk
on some club you know on Ivar some
[ __ ] you got to like talk to people
who are working and understand it and
and that's um that's the kind of thing
like you know like like those kids
you're talking about the Comedy Store
they don't know what the hell's going on
there won't be a comic there's paying $5
to do five minutes that and that's and
that's all they know about the business
and they you know once they get me on
it's it's a Wizard of Oz you want it so
bad you want it so bad but wallet soap
and but you just see like you know you
see Rogen on a special but you don't
understand what Rogan we know what took
together yeah I'm doing them paying for
five minutes to get into that yeah
I always thought that you just went into
a room and talked yeah comedians like
when I watched a Brenna
I figured that he just went somewhere
and they just gave him microphone and he
did a new hour I thought it was that
easy now until you get on stage yeah and
then you're like it's not it you know
like it you're [ __ ] around at work
being funny by the watercooler not the
same thing then you get on stage that's
a big difference now you have to adjust
that calmly and that's a journey just
learning that like before I didn't mean
it that way
I love doing comedy I wouldn't do
anything else it's funny that mine and
rogue Rogan is a complete different
animal and I'm broken to decent
individual but our love is because when
we sit together and talk about Tom it's
a sign it's we head down to a science I
learned from him he learns from me I
just again I don't like all this [ __ ]
that comes with it
I don't like that I'd wanted this to be
like Lenny Bruce yeah I open up for a
few strippers shoot some heroin and we
sleep and we wake up at 2:00 in the
afternoon we only got a freshly squeezed
orange juice yeah
and the doughnut when I met when I read
ladies and gentlemen late Lenny Bruce
yeah that's what I thought this is gonna
be like yeah and it was completely
different
I love the Comedy Store I love what it
represents I love everything about it
yeah
did the only thing I complain I haves
the numbers art meets commerce men that
are F me Scott much wood drumming we
were talking about Led Zeppelin early I
mean like I mean how many those guys
ended up so broke and lost all their
money who was it
um who's the guitarist from said Glenn
Tipton from from whose previous races
got all six right he's having to sell
off his rights to the royalties to the
music that he has because he got
invested in some golf course and went
belly-up and lost everything and like
and he needs medical care now and I mean
this Judas Priest I mean this is like
those guys have been touring since I was
in diapers
yeah 1982 British steel five nights at
the parade a la a [ __ ] theater New
York I think that wasn't def leppard
open for them I think it was Matt laughs
that was early Def Leppard yeah
the night my and dry when they like
sound like ac/dc before they sounded
like for like what poison is ac/dc with
Ted Nugent with Bon Scott at the garden
I'm weekend warriors below and I
withheld talk I saw a way to help to lay
on the green or something like I was a
kid and I saw the I saw I got to see Bon
Scott that was ago that's when this last
night and today I went the freeze yeah
at cryotherapy yeah yeah and I had them
put on squealing oh how long are you in
there for 3 minutes and 15 seconds
that's it that's it
and you cover do you feel it oh yeah
seriously ah feels tremendous I go there
throw punches knees I stretch my back I
throw kicks I do jumping jacks 3 minutes
you breathe just focus on your breathing
Wow all you do is ever done and you
breathe a hammer Donna do bend downs
yeah don't you jump up in the air but
the most important thing cuz it's tubing
fresh oxygen yeah
so your breathing goes back to being
natural and if you don't breathe like
that you know lose it we didn't even run
out of cardio you got to move for three
minutes put on real hook she'd bucking
punches you get chased by eight Porto
Rican cuz I'm saying you're just moving
in there three minutes so if you lose
your breath you're gonna have to open
that door and go out wow you're gonna
have like a panic attack so it's helped
you because he brave it makes that
what's that thing flying or fight
response to be a fire flash it makes
that [ __ ] keep out people yeah a lot
like I freaked out it's now
yeah it's laughs you've gotta go on
there breathe watch the guy yeah and
listen to music I go in there I got five
or six songs I got ready for this one
yeah slaves and bulldozes my [ __ ]
ball bat ball off a Badmotorfinger
absolutely my going at one time I play
that right now service is that ya
rhinosaurus or some hell you've got a
hell you skipped
I play that's one of their songs like
for seven times seven times they Vegas
to see Oh
I'm Matt Cameron they're drummers of oh
and well I lived in Seattle somebody
from that band had a bar I thought bass
player all the drum when he played that
day when he hung out every night you
went to wine a mr. Homma that was a
scene man that was seen and I just you
know wasn't while you sit there you go
Cornell Kurt and an Lane all gone
they're all gone and our boy is still
[ __ ] making music yeah the prodigy
still going to the mall gets a place
does he own that Lee I don't know what
you see the pizza place is just picture
yeah dave grohl car bro right on [ __ ]
rivet right with the old Italian place
used to be there's a pizza place that
opened and that's his neighborhood he
used to go either the Mexican joint told
he's big Tony should be and people the
lady told me he goes he was coming every
day ya know one day we people would
knock on the glass and wave at him we
didn't know who the [ __ ] he was hey bro
thousand dirtbag musician then one day I
go to that mall appear what is appealing
rub with Sherman Oaks Galleria appear
yeah and ice popping that he probably
goes the last time I was here I saw Dave
Grohl getting chased by TMZ and not five
minutes ago
[ __ ] you and it's Dave Grohl running
with his daughter in the mall yes and
then I swap an hour later in like a
luggage store with it yeah just [ __ ]
hanging in here but yeah yeah like that
any better made it maybe maybe there's
any veteran oh it's just a weird curve
once while you started like talking
about all those Seattle bands and you
realize they meant all those things like
let me give some shoutouts I want to
give a shout out to me she who came down
last night my Mangino at speed weed 47
Ronin Adam Hughes Kyle Dempsey my man
Bob Lingus tell your mother I said happy
birthday Christophe Lanka's and sketchy
situation podcast I will be at the
[ __ ] taping this special on the
4th
but I also being loose a casino on June
17th that's my only date in June I'm
relaxing I'm gonna put together the
[ __ ]
package for the book so I got two months
to put a book together been too long my
friend let me ask you something what do
you got coming out you got because you
said you were finishing up a show Yeah
right like we're talking about actors
being scared so the pilot I did didn't
go just finished up this little movie
I've been doing a bunch of stuff with
discovery and travel travel Discovery
Communications bought travel so I've
already shot a pilot for them a history
show that I'm really proud of kind of an
unsung heroes of history we did a great
pilot I don't know if for when it's
gonna air or what network it'll air on I
hope you know it's supposed to be for
travel but travels going through a whole
big big shake-up right now and then I
just I'm executive producing Cousteau's
ocean mysteries actually the Cousteau's
jean-michel Philippe and Celine we're
going science discovery we're doing ten
episodes gotta go put them in some boats
and go look for some stuff I grew up
though everybody did it first family of
the sea I'd love a [ __ ] first day I
was a steel yeah we're Senate were sent
in his son and his grandchildren back
out there yeah I gonna make him look
like he was fighting shark she's
fearless
they're crazy if they think I'm jumping
off the boat with them I'm like I'll
surf with sharks but I go swim down in
their neighborhood I got those people
that walk the tightrope don't lenka's
yeah yeah like that well like this of
the ocean oh yeah I don't do a [ __ ] no
they're dead are all about curiosity
they're all bad they're and they're you
know they're really you know tip of the
spear when it comes to environmental
aspect so we'll be tying in sort of the
you know how the science allows us to
like you know explore the sea in
different ways and also how we can you
know keep preserving our oceans so I
quit it was a pleasure seeing you great
to see my well it's the new season of
one day at a time for me they're right
in there right now so that's that's when
you go back to work I have no idea of if
I'm going back I mean I don't know it
was it was it was yeah it's all good are
you excited about Chicago you see it
useful you will see a huge your city guy
yeah what are you most waiting for right
now I want to see what hat well I you
know I gotta say I mean like DC moving
back up to heavy weight is because if
people forget that he won that you know
the Strikeforce Grand Prix it
heavyweight you know he that he could be
a beast at handy way a beast
if he goes but but steep hey I mean
steep a he's been fighting killers
he's been fighting savages and he you
know it's got a heart of a [ __ ] yeah
and he's guys guy every people don't
quite give him the respect I think that
that he deserves and you know and now
after that last performance by Amanda
Nunez I would have to see her someone's
got a challenge cyborg ya know and so I
don't know but I mean so you know I'd be
up sees just it never ends it's always
fascinating you just name a division
you're not gonna take the top ten on
June 9th we're doing a live thing here
sharing for Romero against with it
that's another one of you Whitakers when
I was welcome to come up I'm gonna take
with me oh that would be fantastic we're
right here we'll play sort of like a
live watch yeah I fight if I can pay my
companion Oh perfect but this has stats
they do it up Matt Militello does it up
really good heavy on sports book TV and
we're also gonna have it at other places
but that's that's gonna be the best
experience and I have all the graphics
yeah so that's what we're doing tonight
whatever time he starts we will be there
[ __ ] nice so I want to thank
you again I wanna thank your key she's
always inspiring the [ __ ] and
I'll see you [ __ ] Memorial Day
ready to go tip-top Magoo thank you very
much mr. Gaylord I love you [ __ ]
I see your Memorial Day have a great
weekend stay safe kick that mule leak
[Music]